hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm learning about the Second
Amendment the US Constitution which
states that a well-regulated militia
being necessary to the security of a
free State the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed to learn more about the Second
Amendment I talked to two experts Alan
Gura is a lawyer who successfully argued
two landmark Second Amendment cases
before the Supreme Court adam winkler as
a professor at UCLA law and the author
of gunfight the battle over the right to
bear arms in America so professor
Winkler why did the framers include an
amendment on the rates to keep and bear
arms well really there's been some
debate over what the meaning of the
right to keep and bear arms is but the
most common view and the view supported
by the United States Supreme Court is
that the Second Amendment protects
individual liberty in particular the
right to keep and bear arms for
self-defense back in the founding era
the framers were concerned about
self-defense in terms of arm to state
militias made up of common citizens who
would prevent federal overreach so the
federal government wouldn't be able to
run roughshod over the liberties of the
people because of these armed state
militias and so the Second Amendment was
in part about protecting those armed
state militias indeed the fear behind
all of the bill of rights was that the
Constitution gave the new federal
government too much power and the
federal government would use that power
to inhibit Liberty and so that was the
self defense of the founding era when we
look at the text the first thing that
people should focus on is the phrase the
right of the people and in particular
the words up before right I think that
might be actually the most important
word in the amendment because we're
tells us is that the right of the people
which is the subject of this amendment
is a pre-existing right and the fact
that this was a pre-existing right tells
us that the framers thought that there
was something that was out there in
their legal system that they were
preserving against violation and in fact
that is the case in English law
since well before the Revolution it had
been settled and determined that people
had an individual right to have arms for
self-protection and this right was
understood to enable people to protect
themselves both against criminal private
violence as well as the right of people
to protect themselves against some
coachmen upon their liberties by by a
tyrant or by a misguided King this was a
right that the framers were
well-acquainted with in English law and
they were very perturbed that the
British during the time the Revolution
were violating this right
there were various instances of the
British disarming Americans obviously in
an attempt to keep the colonists from
revolting and an attempt to prevent them
from resisting the king the the Battle
of Lexington and Concord of course which
started the revolution was nothing but a
British march upon the the Armory's in
those towns in the attempt to to
suppress the the rights of arms and so
what you saw was when the time came for
a Bill of Rights
you saw five out of seven states propose
a bill of rights and the only provisions
common in all the demands for Bill of
Rights were the right to religious
freedom and the right to arms
now the framers were not necessarily
concerned about the sort of modern gun
control which is in controversy today
today we have a different kind of
self-defense we generally think about
with the Second Amendment and that's
about individuals defending themselves
against criminals it's a very personal
kind of Liberty defending yourself
against someone trying to take away your
life your health your property that the
life of your loved ones and one thing
that I think to remember is that this
kind of change in the meaning of a
constitutional amendment over time is
very common among our constitutional
rights as we take the underlying
principles that are embodied in the text
and we apply them to modern
circumstances what about in this early
period with the Artic
of Confederation did state constitutions
also protect the right to bear arms yes
there were state constitutions that
protect the rights of bear arms most
notably the Pennsylvania Constitution
article 13 of the Pennsylvania
Constitution provided quote that the
people have a right to bear arms for the
defence of themselves and the state and
Vermont's Constitution the following
year chapter 1 article 15 copied that
language and you would see other late
18th century early 19th century
constitutions keep this language or some
version of it and what you would notice
is that this language of course talks
about the the two dimensions of the
right to bear arms the people have a
right to bear arms for the defence of
themselves that can only be interpreted
as self-defense and also for the defence
of the state that is they can get they
can use those arms that they
individually have and gather together
and work to defend the society from some
some force that's that's attacking them
this is really fascinating so my
background is in US history
and I know that one of the reasons that
the framers decided that they needed a
constitution that would change the form
of the US government from what it had
been under the Articles of Confederation
was Shay's rebellion when a group of
armed farmers from Western Massachusetts
marched on Springfield so they had kind
of taken their military past as a
militia in the Revolutionary War and
then turned that against the new US
government instead of the British
government did the framers have any
reservations about trying to protect
militias in light of Shay's rebellion
the founders did have concerns about
armed militias as exemplified by Shay's
rebellion they were worried about self
proclaimed militias groups of basically
armed uprisings in disguise that claim
the mantle of a militia but we're really
just troublemakers who were taking up
arms and that was kind of how Shay's
rebellion was thought of at the time and
that's why when we think about the
Second Amendment we should focus on that
language
the framers were sure to include which
is that the militias must be
well-regulated right so the Second
Amendment itself says a well-regulated
militia being necessary for the security
of a free State the right of the people
to keep and bear Arms shall not be
infringed and so they understood that
there was a militia common citizens who
took up arms to help defend the state
and nation but they recognized that the
militia must be well-regulated
disciplined orderly subject to
appropriate command it wasn't a right
for any self-proclaimed group of
radicals to get together and grab their
guns it was instead a right to have an
orderly state militia which was an
important source of national defense at
the time of the founding era so I see
that the 2nd amendment and the 3rd
amendment which bans the government from
quartering soldiers in people's houses
both reflects fears about standing
armies and also the dangers of having
very strong government military power
but today we have a very strong
government military power and a standing
army so to what extent are those
concerns still relevant today
those concerns are still relevant today
we're very blessed in America that we
have a long tradition of civilian
control over the military and in our
culture the military has not been used
to suppress the the people that's our
experience but it has been the
experience sadly in many other places
including through today and what the
Second Amendment reflects is the notion
that the government should not have a
monopoly on force there has to be some
means that people might still retain the
ability to to act to defend themselves
whether that's against a private
individual felon miscreant or whether
it's against something more nefarious
our understanding of what's necessary
for national defense is very different
than it was in the founding era because
our society is so much different
you don't have militias of ordinary
citizens the way we once did back in the
founding era and we don't have troops
occupying people's homes the way the
founders did but nonetheless I think the
second and third amendment both have
principles embodied in that text that
remain relevant for today and should not
be thought of as dead letters just
because the particular concerns that
gave rise to them no longer remain in
our concerns because the principles they
embody are more important and more
enduring we have been blessed with with
peaceful transitions of power with a
vibrant democracy perhaps at least some
aspect of our happy experience relative
to those of our friends and ancestors in
Europe is that we do have a culture that
includes the widespread private arms and
that may have a beneficial effect in
making sure that everybody plays by the
rules that observes normal political
conventions and orbs so what are some of
the major Supreme Court cases that have
shaped our understanding of the Second
Amendment the first one was a case
called United States versus Miller that
arose in the 1930s in Miller you had a
situation where an individual was a
gangster and he was caught with a
sawed-off shotgun which at the time and
still now does require special tax stamp
that mr. Miller did not have and he
argued that the Second Amendment secured
his right to this to this weapon the
government took the case to the Supreme
Court and at the conclusion of the
somewhat confused opinion the Supreme
Court remanded the case back to to the
district court for a determination as to
whether or not the sawed-off shotgun was
an arm of the type whose possession is
protected by the Second Amendment
subsequently mr. Miller was murdered so
perhaps he needed a gun of some kind
after all but we never got the answer to
that question so I would read that case
as other people do and say look
obviously the Supreme Court thought
there was some individual right to arms
if the court had held that there's no
division right to arms that would have
been a much simpler pitting they would
have just said so and that would have
been the end of the matter but instead
because more evidence was needed
relating to whether or not this was an
arm of the type that mr. Miller could
possess that shows that there was some
right there at issue much more helpful
of course is the case that I argued in
the Supreme Court DC versus Heller which
was a coherent detailed fully briefed
and exhaustively opined a matter which
struck down various Washington DC gun
control laws the main laws at issue in
Heller were a district of columbia law
the ban the possession of all handguns
by people effectively and also a law
that prohibited people from having
operative firearms in their home you
could have a long gun a rifle or a
shotgun in your home in DC but you could
never render that operational for use in
self-defense inside your home oddly
enough you could use it in self-defense
in a place of business just not at your
home the most important case on the
Second Amendment is District of Columbia
against Heller where the court held for
the very first time that the Second
Amendment protects an individual right
to bear arms and struck down a gun
control law that was a very important
case a landmark ruling that has led to
many many many court cases challenging
the constitutionality of a wide number
of gun control laws the Supreme Court
has not again stepped into the Second
Amendment with one exception the court
in a case called McDonald versus city of
Chicago how that the Second Amendment
applied equally to the federal
government and to the state and local
governments one thing to remember about
our constitutional rights is that they
don't automatically apply to the state
and local governments but the Macdonald
case held that the Second Amendment and
the principles of the Second Amendment
nonetheless apply to the states as well
and that's pretty common as well over
the course of the 20th century this
Green Court has held that nearly all of
the provisions of the Bill of Rights
apply equally to the state and local
governments
how about limits on the second amendment
I mean I couldn't own a tank right what
sort of limits may the government place
on the right to keep and bear arms well
the Second Amendment like our other
rights has some limitations the first
limitations are of course as with all
rights given to us by the scope of the
actual rights there are many things that
simply aren't included in in a
particular right the right of free
speech for example guarantees you the
right to speak in some ways but perjury
is speech terroristic threats or speech
extortion is a form of speech none of
those are traditionally protected and
likewise there going to be some arms
that are going to fall outside of Second
Amendment protection the Heller case
tells us how to go about discovering
those limits the Amendment we are told
presupposes that people will have arms
that that people would expect to find in
common use for traditional lawful
purposes and so while a handgun or a
rifle is the type of arm that people
would keep for self-defense for hunting
for sport a tank or a bazooka is usually
not something that you would wish to
access for some traditional recognized
lawful activity right I mean very few
people would use a tank to defend
themselves against a mugger on the
street right I mean as a matter of
practicality even if we didn't have a
Second Amendment we there's no possible
way we're going to disarm the entire
civilian population so the guns are here
to stay the question is how can we exist
with civilian armament and good and
effective gun control and I think that
history and tradition can provide some
of those answers in the same way that we
try to understand what is the text of
the Constitution mean and what are the
principles that that text embodies we
look to history and tradition how
Americans lived under that Constitution
over these 200 odd years we should also
look to that history and tradition in
seeing the limits of those
institutional rights and one thing I
think is very clear from the history and
tradition of gun rights and gun
regulation is that there's ample room to
regulate firearms the founding fathers
had gun control laws we had gun control
laws and the Wild West even though that
was the heart of America's gun culture
we've had gun control laws all through
American history and they're part of the
story of the Second Amendment as much as
the six-shooter and the right to bear
arms so we've learned that the framers
concern over protecting the right to
bear arms originated in the experiences
of the American Revolution in which
militias played a central role in
winning independence for the United
States but a lot has changed since the
Revolution the US military has grown and
arms have gotten a lot more powerful
Allen Gura suggests that the lack of a
government monopoly on force is a key
component of the peaceful transitions of
power that characterize American
democracy adam winkler however argues
that there's always been some form of
gun control in the United States even in
the Wild West
to learn more about the Second Amendment
visit the National Constitution centers
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
politics